well we already know that definite
integral's can help us figure out areas
underneath curves or between curves what
we'll show in this video is that you can
actually use pretty much the exact same
principles to figure out the volumes of
rotational solids so what do I mean so
let me let me just draw a couple of
examples so let's say I had let me start
with a fairly straightforward function
that's my y-axis this is my x-axis let
me draw my function let's say my
function looks something I'm going to
draw y equals the square root of x but
I'll keep it general right now just just
so this applies generally to a lot of
things so square root of y equals the
square root of x something like that
alright and it keeps going actually let
me redraw that because I didn't want it
to curve down like that at the end so it
goes up like that and then it just keeps
going up like that that's better okay so
we will call that f of X f of X this is
our x axis this is our Y axis and we
already know that if we wanted to figure
out the area under this curve between
two points let's say between the point a
well I we could do it between any two
points let's say this point a and this
point B and we wanted to find this area
between the two curves
let me I'm drawing everything quicker
today at a different color so that was
so if we wanted the area if we wanted
this area right here we would
essentially just be just as a review be
summing up a bunch of small squares
where each square has a bunch of
rectangles has a width DX and its height
at that point would be whatever x value
here is it would be f of X right and if
we if we take the sum of all of these
areas of all of these rectangles we
would get the area of this curve and we
learned in the definite integral video
the best just equal to the definite
integral from A that's the lower bound
from A to B of f of X
times d of X right we're each rectangles
f of X times G of X and and hopefully
this makes a little bit of intuitive
sense to you I think a lot of people go
through calculus just learning how to do
it
mechanistically just learning you know
how to do it like a robot without really
understanding necessarily what's going
on and if you understand what's going on
you'll never be really lost when when
when when you you see something a little
bit different than what you might have
practiced so with that out of the way
let's think about something what if we
took this function and we rotated it
about the x axis so this might take a
little bit of visualization but you
imagine is let me see if I could draw so
I take this this this curve and if I
were to rotate it about the x axis it
would look something like this it would
look like it would look like a sideways
cup or vase right it would look like
that where that would be the opening
right that would be the opening on the
inside I could even shade it show you my
drawing skills okay hopefully that makes
sense so this was you know that would be
the y axis there and the x axis
let me draw in a different color the x
axis would pop out the middle right
that's if you took this and you rotated
it around so let me draw an arrow to
show that we're rotating it around
rotating around and if we did that what
would be the volume created by well we
could say let's use the same boundaries
between a and B so if we took this piece
and we rotated it around what would it
look like between a and B it would look
something like this
well it would look let me see if I can
draw it so you would have you would have
a whoops I'm not drawing that well this
is really testing the limits of my
ability to use this computer to draw
things so you would have I'm just
drawing it would be kind of a circle on
on one end and then it would curve down
a little bit
it would curve down a little bit and it
would be another circle in the other end
and then if I were to draw the x-axis
the x-axis would kind of pop out of the
middle right there this would be that
right there would be the point B x
equals B and then if we were to let me
do it in a different color if we were to
kind of go behind or look into the
object we would see the other surface of
the of this rotational solid right and
this point right here that would be a
let me draw that in a different color
because it's hard to see that B a and
then of course the x-axis would keep
going and then that would be the y-axis
hopefully that makes it the
visualization it really is the hardest
part about these problems so first this
actually just imagine what you're what
you're doing so and if we were to draw
the whole curve so I just did this
section if I rotated it about the x-axis
but if I were to draw the whole curve
the whole curve would look something
like this right it would look something
like that
and we're just rotating it around
hopefully that makes sense we're
rotating it around that way so how do we
do that well we use the exact same
principle when we figured out the area
we would figure out the area of each of
these small squares and then integrate
we would take the sum of an infinite
number of infinitely small squares and
we got this right so to do the volume
what we do is instead of having each
rectangle we kind of rotate each of
these rectangles around the x axis so if
this is one of the rectangles if that's
the rectangle it has width D let me do a
brighter color it has width DX right
that's my rectangle and it has height f
of X right I'm trying to switch colors
up so this height right here that's f of
X at this point right if I were to
rotate this rectangle around the x-axis
what do I end up with well I'll end up
with the disc
let me see if I can draw that reasonably
well I'm trying to show you some
perspective when I draw it whoops so
that would be the top surface of the
disc and this would be the side of the
disc right and so this is the top
surface of the disc and what would be
the radius of this disc what would be
this height right here
well that radius that's going to be f of
X right that's this height imagine if
you took this and rotated it around
that's the same thing as this height
right here right so that height or the
radius of the disc is f of X and then
what's the width of the disc well that's
just D of X right that's the same thing
as this we just rotated it around so
what would be the volume of the tip of
this disc it would be the area of this
side it'll be this area right here times
this height well what's the area well we
know the air radius right area is equal
to PI R squared what's the radius I keep
drawing over things
what's this radius that radius is f of X
right so the area of this disc the area
of that disc area is equal to PI times
the radius squared so it's pi times f of
X the whole thing squared right so what
would be the volume of this entire disc
so it will just be this area times DX so
the volume I'm running out of space and
colors so the volume of that disk the
volume of that disk is going to be equal
to area of that disk PI f of X squared
right the whole function whatever length
this is at any point squared that gives
us the area times the depth you can say
so that's D of X now that gives us just
the volume of this one disc when it's
rotated around right so if we wanted the
volume of this entire object that I drew
here we would just sum up a bunch of
these discs
right we would take each of these
rectangles rotate it rotate them around
figure out the volume of that disk it
creates and then sum them up and so
essentially we have it we're going to
take an infinite sum of a bunch of these
small little disks so we can take the
integral so this is the volume of each
disk we could call that volume of a disk
so what's the volume of the whole thing
well we just take a sum and if you know
a an integral sum of each of these disks
so the volume when you rotate it is
going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to the definite
integral between and remember our
boundaries were a and B between a and B
of this quantity right here PI F of x
squared d of X DX not D of X DX so
hopefully that makes sense to you just
remember this is the depth this is the
the width of each disks this is the
radius of the disk or the radius of the
surface so we square it and that makes
sense that's the height f of X and we
have 2 PI R squared so that's where the
PI comes from some people just memorize
that I don't recommend you do that and
we'll see that later but I'm out of time
in the next video I'll actually apply
this to an actual problem see you soon